okay dreams
you
good afternoon there are three things i
want to
speak briefly today with you all about
the new new milestone and our progress
against covet 19 here at home
steps we're taking to fight covenant
internationally
and an important tax cut for families
with children
under the age of 18. and that's where
i'm going to start
today's tax day when uh when
everyone's taxes are due no one likes to
pay taxes i know
but my dad just says a small price to
live in this country
but until children why
as they're fitting their texas filing
their taxes today
they should know that a new tax cut will
be coming
their way for working class and
middle-class folks and very soon as
everyone knows
i firmly believe we firmly believe the
need to make
our tax system work for the middle class
that's why i think
we should ask corporations in the top
one percent to start paying their fair
share
and why we should crack down on
millionaires and billionaires who escape
taxes by cheating
but i also think we need to give
ordinary families a break
a tax break to help them with the cost
of raising their kids
most people don't know it but for
families with children
we uh we put that tax cut into the
american rescue plan which was signed
not long ago and i signed the tax cut
into law
in march 90 of the families all middle
class
working class families will get this tax
cut
it's a one-year cut that reduces your
taxes by
three thousand dollars a year for each
child you have under the age of 18.
two kids it's a six thousand dollar tax
cut
and if those kids are under the age of
six they'll actually get
three thousand six hundred dollars per
child so
as you file your taxes a day know that
your tax cut is coming but this here's
the great news
you won't have to wait until your next
year's tax return to get that break
i'm announcing today that on july 15
and the 15th of every month thereafter
throughout the year
you will get deposited in your bank
account half
of your tax cut at least 250
per child each month a direct deposit
into your account
so if you're a working family with two
kids you're going to get
500 a month into your bank account on
the 15th of every month starting july
we're getting uh and and we're getting
you
a tax cut this year now when you need it
and not have to wait
and if you get your tax cut refund
deposited in your bank account
automatically
this tax cut will be put into your
account automatically
if not it will be mailed to you in
addition to helping americans
hard-pressed
and working families experts have told
us this will cut
child poverty in america in half this
tax cut
sends a clear and powerful message to
american workers
working families with children help is
here
now let me take talk to another
milestone in a long battle with covin
today for the first time since the
pandemic began cases
pandemic cases are down in all
50 states first time that's right
thanks a lot to the hard work of so many
people covet cases are down in
all 50 states now i can't promise that
will continue this way
we know there will be advances and
setbacks and we know that there are many
flare-ups that could occur but if the
unvaccinated get vaccinated
they will protect themselves and other
unvaccinated people
around them if they do not states with
low vaccination rates may see
those rates go up may see this progress
reversed
ultimately those who are not vaccinated
will
end up paying the price the vaccinator
will continue to be protected against
severe illnesses
but others may not be if you're not
vaccinated but given that the
vaccination is convenient
and free it'll be a tragedy
if it's a needless one to see covert
cases among those
who do not get vaccinated go up we're
not done fighting this virus
we spent 10 million love acting
but we are making significant progress
in fact
when tomorrow's vaccination numbers come
out they'll
show that sixty percent sixty percent of
the americans have received at least one
shot
every day the light into that tunnel has
grown brighter
this vaccination effort has been a
historic logistical achievement for our
nation
and i want to thank the scientists and
the researchers
the companies manufacturing the vaccines
the national guard the u.s military
fema the nation's governors doctors
nurses
pharmacists i want to thank the american
people
who have stepped up and done their
patriotic duty and gotten vaccinated
in less than four months we've gone from
less than
six percent to sixty percent of adults
in america
with at least one shot we're seeing the
results in
live and we've seen the results in
people's lives
and in their livelihoods deaths are down
from covet by 81
and also at their lowest level since
april of 2020.
as a result of our prompt action to roll
out the vaccine and boost the economy
we've gone from stagnation to an economy
that is growing faster than it has in
nearly 40 years
we've gone from anemic job creation to a
record of creation
for more for a new administration none
has ever created this many jobs in this
time frame the progress is undeniable
but we're not done yet and some of the
hardest work is ahead
we're still losing too many americans
and we still have too many unvaccinated
people in america
last week the cdc announced that if
you're fully vaccinated you no longer
have to wear a mask
they reported that science the science
now shows
that your vaccination protects you as
well as being masked
or better than being masked so you can
protect yourself from serious illness
from covid
by getting vaccinated or wearing a mask
until you're fully vaccinated
either way you're protected as i said
last week
some people may want to continue to wear
a mask even if they are fully vaccinated
that's a decision they can make some
businesses may want
to continue to require wearing masks
let's all be kind and respectful to one
another
as we come out of this pandemic and
respect those who want to continue to
wear a mask even if they've been
vaccinated
above all let's work together though to
meet
the target i've said of 70 percent of
adults
all adults with at least one shot by
july the 4th
seven states have already done this
getting vaccinated has never been
easier we are 80 000 locations where you
can get a shot
90 of you live within 5 miles of one of
those locations
you can now find a vaccine site near you
by texting your zip
code to 438829
438829 your zip code
and that number you'll get all the
places near you
many places don't require an appointment
just walk in and get the shot
it's free and everyone 12 years and
above is eligible
if you need help getting your vaccine
site
getting to or from your vaccination
vaccination site
lyft and uber are offering free rides
be to take you to the vaccination site
and bring you back home
between may 24th and july the 4th
to anyone who wants to get vaccinated
and i've called on employers to do their
part as well
offering their employees paid time
off to get vaccinated and we've set up a
program nationally
to reimburse those businesses for the
cost of giving employees the time
off now it's time to get your shot
we have the vaccine we've secured enough
supply to vaccinate
all adults and children above the age of
12.
i repeat now is the time to get your
vaccine shot
now over the past 118 days
our vaccinations program has led the
world
and today we're taking an additional
step
to help the world we know america will
never
be fully safe until the pandemic is
raising globally is under control
no oceans wide enough no walls high
enough to keep us safe
rampant disease and death in other
countries can destabilize them
those countries and pose a risk to us as
well
new variants could arise overseas that
could put us at greater risk
and we need to help fight the disease
around the world to keep
us safe here at home and to do the right
thing of helping other people it's the
right thing to do
it's the smart thing to do it's the
strong thing to do
in march we shared over 4 million doses
of our astrozenica vaccine with canada
and mexico
at the end of april we announced that we
would provide another 60 million
doses of our vaccine overseas
remember this is the vaccine that's not
authorized for use in the united states
yet so we're going to be sending it
to folks once the fda's reviewed this
and said it's safe this is all the
astromedical vaccine produced in the
united states all of it
will be sent to other countries and
today
i'm announcing they will also share u.s
authorized vaccine doses of pfizer and
moderna
and johnson and johnson as they become
available with the rest of the world as
well
these are vaccinations and vaccines that
are authorized to be put in arms of
americans
and by the end of june when we will have
taken delivery of enough of such
vaccines to protect
everyone in the united states the united
states will share at least
20 million of those doses that extra
supply with other countries
this means over the next six weeks the
united states of america will send
80 million doses overseas
that represents 13 percent of the
vaccines produced by the united states
by the end of june
this will be more vaccines than any
country has actually
shared to date five times more than any
other country
more than russia china which have
donated 15 million doses
you know there's a lot of talk about
russian china influencing the world with
vaccines
we want to lead the world with our
values
with this demonstration of our
innovation and ingenuity
and the fundamental decency of the
american people
just as in world war ii america was the
arsenal of democracy in the battle
against covet 19 pandemic
our nation is going to be the arsenal of
vaccines for the rest of the world
we'll share these vaccines in the
service of ending the pandemic
everywhere
and we will not use our vaccines to
secure favors from other countries
we'll work with kovacs the international
organization set up
and other partners to ensure that the
vaccines are delivered in a way that is
equitable
and follows the science and the public
health data
today's announcement to share 80 million
doses
is our next step as we ramp up the
efforts to respond to covet 19 around
the world
in the weeks ahead working the world
with the world's democracies
we'll coordinate a multilateral effort
to end this pandemic
i expect to announce progress in this
area
at the g7 summit the united kingdom in
june which i plan on attending
this is a unique moment in history and
it requires
american leadership but i want to be
clear
beating this pandemic globally is beyond
the capacity of any one nation
even the united states but we'll
continue the united states will continue
to donate
our excess supply as that supply is
delivered to us
but that won't be nearly enough we need
what we need to do is lead an entirely
new effort
an effort that involves working with the
pharmaceutical companies and others
and partner nations to vastly increase
supply to create
particular most of it here in the united
states the kind of capacity
that can beat this pandemic worldwide in
a way that creates jobs here at home and
saves lives abroad
this will take longer than our immediate
work to donate from the existing
supplies
and we're going to be asking other
nations to help shoulder the economic
cost of this effort
but the consequences will be more
lasting and more dramatic
doing this will help us beat the
pandemic and leave us with a
manufacturing capacity here to prepare
for the next
crisis the next vaccine needed
i'm putting jeff zions who's leading our
cova team
and the covet efforts to beat the virus
here in the united states in charge of
this effort
jeff will be working with our national
security council
and a talented dedicated team that has
been stood up
all across our government it will
include gail smith at the state
department leading in diplomacy
and experts from our agency of
international development
and the department of health and human
services as well
we're going to bring the same whole
government response to the global effort
that made us so successful here at home
again we have enough we have
we the united states has secured enough
supply
for all elements of americans all
americans
12 years 12 years old and older
and we still have work to do though hard
work
but because we have done so much here
because of the power of american
companies research and manufacturing
we can continue to do more to help the
rest of the world
this was a rapidly changing world and
it's a mistake
to bet against democracies just as
democracies led the world in the
darkness of world war
ii democracy will lead the world out of
this pandemic
and america will lead those democracies
as they work to bring
greater health and hope to the world of
the months to come
and folks think back four months ago
four months ago was audacious goal that
we had
to put a million shots in the arms in my
first hundred days as president
100 million i should say we did over 220
million shots in that time frame back
then
most adults weren't eligible to get the
shot now everyone
12 years older is eligible and tomorrow
60 by tomorrow 60 percent of all
american adults will have received at
least one shot
look what we've done look what we've
done america
look at what you've done america there's
not a single thing beyond our capacity
to do in this country we decide to do it
and we do it together
we can do whatever set our minds to do
if we do it together
that's exactly we're going to do solve
the problem here in the united states
which we're well on our way of doing
and help solve the problem for the world
by organizing the rest of the
democracies of the world
i want to thank you all god bless you
and may god protect our troops thank you
mr president
mr president given the escalation of
violence
mr president will you now insist upon a
ceasefire given the escalation of
violence we've seen over the weekend
i'll be speaking with the prime minister
an hour and i'll be
able to talk to you after that do you
still believe you've defended israel's
right to defend itself do you still
believe its actions are
proportionate to what they're facing